[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique
] c'était une très belle offre du président
Poutine et j'aurais pu dire non merci
ou j'aurais pu dire merci
et j'ai dit que j'accepterais et maintenant il est
temps de présenter mon
co spécial  -hôte mr donald trump
merci beaucoup susan d'être ici
c'est le nom de nikki tout ce que vous voulez
nommer je veux dire je ne sais pas
comment pourrais-je combattre les nouvelles qui sont malhonnêtes
comment pourrais-je combattre un journaliste ou un
réseau qui est totalement malhonnête cnn est
vous  je sais que c'est négatif à cent pour cent
je ne peux pas lire ça
ils changent vite le changement est si rapide
parfois je dirai
wow ça va être une belle histoire je
serais un assez bon journaliste pas aussi bon que
toi j'adore cette idée  je pense que je peux le
faire c'est un
pays incroyable avec vous connaissez tant d'amis en
russie
et je suis très excité d'être ici
ils sont très gentils je gagne beaucoup d'argent
avec eux ils me paient des
millions et des centaines de millions
oh voici  un beau en voici un beau un
grand mur et personne ne construit de
murs mieux  un moi croyez-moi
et je les construirai à très peu de frais un
grand
grand mur
et juste au cas où vous vous inquiétez de savoir
qui va payer le mexique le paiera
[Musique]
nous verrons ce qui se passera qui sait je
dis toujours  qui sait
mais on verra on a le sentiment qu'on va
[Musique]
réussir